speaking of school happening today ccsd
will swear in three new board members
they were elected by parents back in
november during the election
hector mejia live at school district
headquarters to explain what's at stake
hi hector happy monday
hey there alex good morning to you and
this is happening as the school board is
trying to decide how to safely reopen
schools the vast majority of students
have not stepped into a physical
classroom
since march and the new board members
will have a say in that as early as next
week
the new board members are lisa guzman
katie williams and evelyn garcia morales
long time board members have been termed
out at tonight's meeting they'll join
board
president lola brooks who won
re-election in november
last month ccsd announced it reached a
tentative agreement with the largest
teachers union for potential
face-to-face instruction
the plan also allows flexibility
educators can choose whether or not to
return to in-person instruction
the first phase of that plan would
include only pre-k
through third grade when asked why
superintendent dr jesus jarrah said
younger students were chosen because
they are most likely to need social and
physical education
studies also show that they are least
likely to spread the virus
and the new trustees will vote on that
plan next week thursday january 14th
at least one new school board member
katie williams is an
outspoken proponent of reopening schools
she campaigned heavily on that issue and
won
her race by a wide margin and even if
the school board
votes for the agreement next week
there's still no timeline for reopening
and i talked with the superintendent
here during a press conference last
month
he told me they were looking at a number
of factors not just the coronavirus
positivity rate
as they try to decide when they can
reopen the schools
as far as tonight's ceremony it's not
open to the public but you can watch it
online
it'll be live stream starting at 5 30 pm
reporting live near saharan decatur
hector mejia
8 news now